Speaker 1: There is something going on with
this 2024 presidential primary that should
interest political scientists, psychologists,
sociologists. It it's unbelievable the dynamic
that has developed between Nikki Haley, who
announced her candidacy on Tuesday against
Donald Trump and Trump himself. Trump very quickly
jumping out and attacking Nikki Haley as terrible
at her job. Nikki Haley not attacking Trump,
in fact, not even drawing any distinctions. And
yesterday morning, she appeared on Fox and
Friends. She's been going around saying we
need a cognitive tests for politicians over age
75. Now, she mostly means it because of Biden.
But she's argued the real advantage to her
over Trump is she's from a new generation,
which means she's younger. So in some sense, Trump
being 76 and Nikki saying, if you're 75 or older,
you should take a cognitive test. It also
applies to Trump. So the Fox and Friends
crew asks Nikki Haley about it and says, Well,
how would Trump do on that test? Because he's
also of that age. Nikki doesn't take the
bait. Refusing to criticize Donald Trump.
Speaker 2: How would Donald Trump do on
the competency test if at at 76 years old?
Speaker 3: You know, I think he did
great the last time he did it. I have
no reason to think he wouldn't do well this time.
Speaker 1: He identified the tiger. It was great.
Speaker 3: But I do think we need it. And
it's across the board. I don't think it's
for president. I think you look at Congress, look
at all the members of Congress. You have to start
doing this for elected officials. When people send
someone to Washington, they need to know they're
at the top of their game. That's why I think
those competency tests are important. We can't
have someone like Joe Biden who's asleep at the
wheel and have China sitting there threatening us
and us wondering if he actually knows what's
going on. China is good for America to do.
Competency tests. This isn't about one person.
Speaker 1: Yeah. So refusing to criticize Donald
Trump, this is the funniest sort of dance that's
taking place here. Do I criticize Trump? Don't I?
Well, I am running against him, but I also
don't want to go against him too hard. And
maybe she's actually running to be Trump's
VP. That's another thing that occurred to
me. This is really a campaign so that she runs
a campaign doesn't insult Trump. And then if
she does well enough, maybe Trump invites
her to be his running mate. I don't know.
This campaign is palpably palpable. You could
just feel it. It's thick. It's going nowhere.
In another moment during the same interview, she
said, Donald Trump is my friend. Yeah. It's not in
exactly that way. Take a listen to this.
Speaker 3: When you flip around
to other channels or even, you know, when
we interview Democrats on this channel,
they say you flip flop. One minute you're friends
with Donald Trump, the next minute you're not. How
do you answer that?
Speaker 1: Yeah.
Speaker 3: Well, first of all, President
Trump is my friend. I was honored to work
with him in castration. I thought he was
the right president at the right time. And
that remains to be the truth. We had a great
conversation. I told him that I was doing this
because I thought it was time for a new
generation. I thought we needed to lead.
Speaker 1: I told him, You're too old.
Speaker 3: And we needed to move forward.
Speaker 1: So. I just don't even know where
to start. First of all, is it possible
that Trump actually does want Nikki Haley to
run? It is possible. And I keep going back
to the same reason why when you look at 2024
Republican primary polling, when it's Trump
versus de Santos head to head. DeSantis does
way better and sometimes is actually winning.
When you have a poll that is, do you want Trump
or DeSantis or Pence or Don Jr. Or Mike Pompeo or
Nikki Haley or Roger Stone or Alex Jones, who
have the more people you stuff into the poll.
The better Trump does, because a lot of those
other choices take away more from the Santas
than they do from Trump right now. So one could
make the argument Trump wants as many people as
possible to run because it hurts DeSantis and
it helps him. That's a possibility. Secondly,
is there any shot that Nikki Haley wins this
nomination? If she refuses to go head on
and criticize Trump and by criticize, I don't
even mean insult. I just mean draw some policy
distinctions. Right. Do something to show other
than just being young and a minority and a woman,
which is the identity politics that Nikki played
at her first rally, which we covered yesterday,
which took place Wednesday. You have no
chance. And the same applies to Ron DeSantis,
but differently with Ron DeSantis. I think
DeSantis, if he does run for the nomination,
has to abandon taking the high road because it's
just not what Republican voters seem to want. But
with Nikki Haley's campaign, if all you're going
to say is Trump is my friend and you're not going
to criticize him in terms of policy, you're not
going to suggest, yeah, the cognitive test is for
Trump, too, because he might be You're going
absolutely nowhere. There's just no way. And
if her intention is really just to be the V.P.
rather than be the nominee, then maybe this is
the right approach. It's just not clear what
she's thinking. We should figure out, is she
coming up with these ideas or are these the ideas
of her advisers? Is she waiting to transition in
the. Here's what what is different about me?
I don't know the answer, but this is already a
completely insane primary. We will have the clips
they played for you here on our YouTube channel,
YouTube.com slash The David Pakman Show. And this
clip will be dubbed into Spanish and available on
the Spanish YouTube channel, which you can find at
David Pakman dot com slash Spanish. Check it out.